[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss I'm happy today I'm
happy because I get to have a
conversation with my friend Seth Godin
Seth is a frequent flyer on this podcast
for those of you who do not know who
Seth is Seth Godin is the author of 21
count of 21. international bestsellers
you eclipsed the fingers and the toes 21
International bestsellers that have
changed the way people think about work
and much more I'm going to add that on
my addendum his books have been
translated into 38 languages and Seth's
books include tribes Purple Cow linchpin
the dip and this is marketing Seth
writes one of the most popular marketing
blogs in the world and he covers much
more than marketing I should say and two
of his TED Talks are among the most
popular of all time he is the founder of
the alt MBA the social media Pioneer
squidu and yoyodine one of the first
internet companies so he's seen many
chapters many moons his new book is the
song of significance a new Manifesto for
teams you can find find all things Seth
at sethgoden.com and Seth's
dot blog Seth so nice to see you
hey Tim this is a great excuse I would
rather cook you dinner but this is a
close second
I will take you up on both and I thought
we would begin with what is present for
me at the moment and you are very
gracious in being flexible with our
start time I went in to see a an
ophthalmologist for the first time in
many years and he he also happens to be
a surgeon but I wasn't going there for
any type of surgery and I did not
anticipate when I had all the drops put
into my eyes that I would be completely
incapacitated for two to six hours I
couldn't see anything within 12 inches
of my face they gave me some throwaway
glasses basically just to get the job
done so I could at least call an Uber
and get home and we pushed our start
time
and the net net of it was your eyesight
like everything else is aging it's still
very very good at least my distance is
2015 which is fantastic but it's not
what it once was 2010 and I had I want
to say a moment of crisis when he's when
he basically took a card and put it in
front of me while my eyes were blurry
and he said this is where your vision is
going just so you know so this bedside
manner could have used a little bit of
work but I wanted to ask you how you
think about or relate to aging and the
changes that come with aging
what a great place to start you know I
mean I was on the internet in 1976
before many people listening to this
were born and when I started one of the
first internet companies there wasn't a
world wide web so the world keeps
changing and so do we and it's very
tempting because the stars in front of
us keep changing and getting younger to
imagine that we are sort of fading away
and so my analogy
my dad taught me to ski when I was 12.
and I was terrible at Ball Sports not
very good at hockey I hated getting
hit I broke my nose I broke my arm but
skiing I was a maniac nobody there were
no helmets in those days but no one
could get downhill faster than me and
when I was 16 I fell under the chairlift
at Sugarbush on the ice
and skid skidded the whole way from the
top to the bottom face down head first
dislocating both shoulders
and ended up needing surgery on both the
first one was botched by a neighbor the
second one was by the doctor for the US
ski team and
I said I can't ski anymore but when my
kids came along I taught them to ski and
I got back into it with my dad
and then I realized when I hit like 35
you're just gonna have to keep
confronting the fact that you're afraid
and you're not
gonna get better at this so I switched
to Telemark skiing which is twice the
work in
half the speed and I did that for 10
years and then I switched to skate
skiing with Nordic skis and I get to
still do that and it's very easy when I
think about my lack of recall that I
used to have where I could run a seven
hour session
without repeating myself
to my inability to ski anymore to 17
other things that I'm walking away from
and to feel a sense of loss to feel like
we need to grieve that we're not that
person anymore
but I guess after
my first bout with covid it was more
like what a gift I have today to be
in the shoes of somebody who at 62 gets
to do things well but only because I'm
walking away from things I can't do
anymore and instead of focusing on what
I used to have I'm really working hard
and getting satisfaction out of focusing
on what I do have what I can do and that
just raises the stakes for things and
the reason that this is interesting I
think is because Boomers and I'm a
little bit a lot older than you but
Boomers have driven our culture since
the day I was born that when
we were draft age that was when the
draft really mattered and when we were
listening to rock and roll that's when
music really mattered and when people
needed to make money for their family
that's when Wall Street really mattered
and now boomers are dying and so we are
living in a culture where there's an
overag of all these people with loud
voices talking about the end of the
world because it's the end of their
world but it's not the end of the world
um
I thought you might have
a few things to share on this subject so
that was a rant to get us started oh my
goodness you just bought permission to
talk about whatever you want that put a
salve on my existential crisis wound
that I had earlier today but before we
move on let me ask you on a day-to-day
week-to-week basis you strike me and
have struck me for a long time as a
let's say default optimistic generally
if we consider Baseline to be emotion
neutral generally above Baseline person
are there times when you catch yourself
perhaps
focusing on noticing dwelling is too
strong a word but ruminating on the loss
of something and in those cases what do
you do I'm just wondering what the
intervention looks like what the
self-talk looks like anything like that
so I really wish you had a chance to
interview Zig Ziglar
was my friend he was one of my first
teachers and one of the things I took
away from Zig as someone who had gotten
himself into a pessimistic cycle for
five years earlier in my career is the
world is going to be whatever the world
is approaching it with a positive
energetic attitude probably will make
your experience of the world better
than girding Yourself by being a
pessimist and maybe getting what you're
hoping for
so
I find myself coming back frequently
particularly in the last bunch of years
when there's been so much Doom and Gloom
to this idea that we get to pick our
attitude and in fact it's the only thing
each of us truly gets to pick
and it doesn't mean what happened to you
is what you deserve it just means that
that happened now you get the one and
only choice which is how to process that
so that's not the answer to your
question but that's my Approach
but I find myself in negative ruts
when I'm confronted by too much media
when I first started organizing the
carbon Almanac there was a full two
months when the cataclysm that we have
created was confronting me really
directly and it was hard to find my
footing
speaking of response and choosing
response and I don't want to
Shuffle the deck in such a way that
makes things difficult but we spoke a
little bit before we began recording
about the several thousand things that
we could discuss and one name came up
which was Victor Frankl and would this
be an opportune time we can always hit
snooze and come back to Victor but
should this be an opportune time to
invoke the name Victor Frankel and let
you run with it
there are a few books that have been
brought up on this podcast more than
that one very few and Victor frankl's
story survival of four concentration
camps just generous heroic
the thing is a lot of people stop
reading halfway through the first book
that they touch of his because the story
is really powerful but then you get to
this stuff about Lobo therapy and some
people say that he was part of the Triad
of Austrian
Pioneers in the way we think about the
mind there was Freud who focused on
sensuality and sex there was Adler who
focused on status dominance and then
there was Frankel who focused on meaning
and meaning as far as I can tell from my
limited reading of Frankel's work
is
when a human being finds
a thing that means something to them a
chance for a path forward a pathway to
Hope
everything in their life gets better
and that his work he lived for another
70 years after he got out of the camp 65
years his work and suicide prevention
was extraordinary from the statistics
I've read because he understood that for
many people I'm not generalizing
everyone but for many people
finding a path toward hope of meaning of
realizing that the struggle is the
struggle but you get to decide what to
do with it
is really profound and I think as our
industrialized world has gotten more
narcissistic which basically says
marketers need to make you uncomfortable
so that you will buy more stuff to feel
better about yourself and your standing
marketers are trying to push people to
find meaning in purchases
and the problem with that also in
friends and likes and social media
nonsense the problem with that is it
doesn't scale
and after you've got one storage room
full of stuff buying more things doesn't
seem to help you find more meaning
and I really feel like we're in this
moment in our culture This Moment In
Time
where people are waking up and saying
thank you very much but I don't need to
buy another thing what I need to do is
find something to care about
and I'll finish this with a two-parter
about I went to see a a community
Orchestra last week my friend is in it
all volunteers and the thing about
Community orchestras is there are
violinists and floutists and nobleists
who get paid money to do it but no one
in the community Orchestra is saying why
aren't I getting paid
because that's not why they're there in
fact they often pay to be there
and I'm guessing with no data whatsoever
that if you surveyed people who are in
community orchestras they probably index
happier and more engaged in life than
people who aren't
and so the question is where are we
going to find our community Orchestra
for me the last year and a half it was
the carbon Almanac I have 1900 friends
in 90 countries around the world I ran
into a bunch of them yesterday Union
Square and they're not doing it for
money none of us got paid they're not
doing it for me I wasn't even there
until I showed up at the end of the day
they're doing it because the meaning
that they get from it is so valuable
it gives them a reason to put up with
all the other stuff they have to do
every day
um
I think we should take a moment just for
those who are not familiar to provide a
little bit of background just a brief
description of what the carbon Almanac
is and then we can
navigate from there
so as you so generously said
I've written 20 books I wrote permission
marketing which invented the
business of email marketing and I wrote
a book called Purple Cow
but I don't need to write books I don't
wake up in the morning the way I used to
say what I do for a living is write
books what should I write about now I
only write one when I have no choice
and
two and a half years ago
I read the Magnificent Ministry for the
future by Kim Stanley Robinson and it
completely
upended the way I saw the world it was
astonishing to me how much I didn't know
about what was happening to the climate
and I realized that I wasn't talking
about what marketing and corporations
were doing to the climate because I felt
stupid and the reason I felt stupid is
they wanted me to feel stupid that they
want us to be confused and I thought
well if I'm under informed I bet other
people are too
and I used to make almanacs for a living
I did the business almond act the People
magazine celebrity Almanac I know how to
make a complicated long book
but I realized hey it would take me too
long and B would be really lonely so
what an opportunity I downloaded
discourse set it up invited some people
to join me and within a month we had 300
volunteers most of whom I have never met
in person
and in 150 days we built edited
footnoted researched copy edited
Illustrated a 97 000 word book with no
errors in it all as volunteers around
the world 24 hours a day trading shifts
and the process of building it found
solace for all of us and I learned so
much which I Incorporated in the new
book about what a community can do when
people are enrolled and I also learned a
lot like plastic recycling is a fraud
and Exxon
knew long ago about
what was happening to the climate and my
favorite is that carbon footprint the
concept was invented by Ogilvy and
Mather for their client British
Petroleum as a way of getting privileged
people to feel guilty about their
behavior and if you feel like a
hypocrite maybe you won't speak up
so where should we go here if we we find
ourselves at a multi-pronged fork in the
road we can talk about industrialism
we could talk about building Community
which is something that is certainly on
my mind but I don't want to
hijack I can try to
coax and direct but I don't want to
hijack if it's not a natural place to go
we could talk about creativity trust
enrollment I'm choosing a few words here
and there that come to mind
AI of course on many people's minds but
perhaps you could speak to
the antidote to nihilism and I want to
preface that just by saying when you
talk about
marketers and corporations I would like
to say and I think it's fair to say that
you come from the place of someone who
has worn the Hat of marketer you come
from a place of someone who has worn the
Hat of founder of executive and
therefore I give it much more
credibility than I would someone with 27
bumper stickers from 27 causes driving
around in Berkeley who's never really
worked in an office or in a business of
any type who's spouting off about the
evil corporations in the same way that
someone might talk about the evil
Illuminati that I want to establish with
that backdrop could you speak to how you
think about
nihilism and addressing nihilism because
certainly even in my audience and
particularly among younger people but I
have seen it
bleeding upward into my generation even
people who are older than me
what appears to be this creeping
nihilism the sense that
nothing means anything you can't sort
true from false right from wrong
everything's too confusing we have deep
fakes misinformation disinformation you
just can't sort anything from anything
else and on top of that
it seems like
the Titanic
has already hit the iceberg we're on the
way down you can't really patch the hole
so is the best we can do playing violins
on the deck while she goes under or is
there anything else to do that is maybe
an overstatement but not much of one
this is something that I really do sense
in
many interactions that I've
seen and felt
and I would just love to know how you
have thought about that because I have
found myself similar to where you found
yourself perhaps at one point with a
carbon Almanac
in a malaise and some would say well
it's a Well warranted place so what are
you going to do about it and I would
love to know what you suggest we do
about it or what you have done about it
aside from the putting together the
carbon Almanac itself
longest question of all time thank you
for listening no it's a great question
it's a great question and you should be
driving because you know exactly what's
going on
I'm going to start by saying I'm a
hypocrite and so is everybody else
and so I don't have to point out that
I'm more pure than other people because
I'm not now after just a few minutes of
the podcast we have to put onto the
table a very simple statement which is
we're all gonna die
but
that was true 50 years ago too
and there's a great book that I loved
called the last policeman
and
I'm not sure I'd say it's a great book
it's a great concept and I really love
reading it imagine that there's an
asteroid that's going to hit the earth
in a year and Destroy and kill all of us
it's not don't look up it just starts
with that premise and then it's a police
procedural book about the last policeman
left in a little village in New
Hampshire because everybody else says
screw it we're all going to be dead in a
year
so marriages break up why would you go
to work to clean the fryer if you know
you only have a year left to live
supermarkets fall apart there's you know
but he goes to work every single day
because we're all going to die maybe not
in a year but no one listening to this
is going to be alive in a hundred years
even some Silicon Valley billionaires
were getting blood transfusions aren't
going to be alive right and so the only
question is are you going to die in a
year or 100 years and when we look at
the data on the climate it's very clear
that they're going to be 10 20 30 40
million climate refugees every year that
whole swaths of the Earth are going to
become uninhabitable it's not going to
be pleasant for many people
can we quote fix it and go back to I
don't know when no
is it a problem that we should address
definitely
but that doesn't mean
we could do anything to live forever
so given that we're all gonna die the
question is what's the point of tomorrow
and for me
I think the key question coming at this
as someone went to Stanford Business
School a very long time ago is some
people believe that the purpose of
business is to enable culture to enable
humanity and some people believe that
the purpose of humanity and culture is
to enable business
and I think those people have too much
influence right now and they are wrong
and Milton Friedman just made up this
nonsense about the only purpose of a
corporation is to maximize its profit it
lets people off the hook and they become
tools of a system that grinds stuff out
so if we think about Amazon Amazon has
had turnover as high as 30 percent in a
90-day period 30 percent of all the
people they hired across the whole
company quit in less than 90 days that
the data that I quote in the book
is that it cost Amazon a third of their
profit a third of their total profit
because of turnover
and the reason is simple because when
you get there to work in a warehouse and
more than half of all the warehouse
injuries in the United States happen in
an Amazon warehouse last year
this don't treat you like a person they
say your job is to beat the numbers on
this sheet of paper or on this iPad
screen and then beat them again tomorrow
it's Frederick Taylor on steroids with a
stopwatch jerking people around the
expression jerking people around came
from Ford's assembly plant in the 1920s
because Frederick Taylor and Henry Ford
used a stopwatch to measure every single
motion and a visitor to the Ford plant
said it looks like everyone here is
wound up the way they are jerking from
left to right with strings pulling them
it's a wonder that they can even live
and
when we think about tomorrow or the
tomorrow after that given the damage
we've all done we still live in culture
we still have this miracle you and I are
talking well thousands of miles apart we
have access to every piece of
information we have magical computers
that can understand us and talk back we
can reach out to someone in need we can
connect to people who need to hear from
us and if you wanna
just give up because the world is going
to be different in 20 years that's your
choice
but given that we've got this window it
feels to me like we need to up our focus
on humanity and connection and
possibility and Improvement of the
condition
and maybe not worry so much about you
know public demonstrations of power
firing people online
being brutal in the service of profit
because we don't have a profit shortage
we have a meaning shortage
so what can someone listening do you
could personalize this to me if you like
I'm always looking for meaning it seems
to be a perennial subject for me
what can someone do
if they are listening and thinking
it is not my path or I don't have the
bandwidth or fill in the blank to become
say a climate activist not to say that's
what you're implying but what else can I
do to
be part of the light and not part of the
dark so to speak
so in a second I want to talk about the
bees but first
significance so I surveyed 10 000 people
and I said tell me about the best job
you ever had
and I gave people 14 choices about what
made it the best job they ever had
including they paid me a lot of money
and I didn't have to work very hard and
the results were the same no matter
which country people came from no matter
how old they were the results were I
accomplished more than I thought I could
people treated me with respect and I did
work I was proud of
if we feel significance we start to feel
optimistic we start to feel meaning we
start to feel human
where does significance come from
it comes from making a change happen
can you be really clear about the change
you seek to make and who you are making
it with and for
so when I think about climate most of
the people who showed up to work on the
carbon Almanac said well I'm doing fine
I recycle this I compost that I don't do
that
and
this is the myth of the carbon footprint
there is nothing you can do personally
as a privileged person of the colonial
world to fix the climate
but what you can do is organize
that if you can figure out how to get
five or ten people together you can
probably ban gas powered leaf blowers in
your village
and that will have 50 times the impact
of you switching to an electric car
plus the idea of banding together with 5
or 10 or 15 other people creating the
conditions for other people to find
something to care about and succeed at
it
will fill you with meaning not with
despair
but leaving the climate aside for a
minute when we think about our days
where we go to work who we work with
whether we're in a community Orchestra
or not
is it significant is it about you and
the change you seek to make or are you
quote I'm just doing my job
so I'm doing a talk for Harvard and they
said what do you want to call it
and I told them and they renamed it
which I got them to unrename to
having your employees feel significant
like as if it's some sort of hand waving
that you get to do with the free snacks
and that's not my point my point is we
built all these systems so we can
actually be significant so we can
actually point to what we made so let's
go back how long ago was the first break
to a book for you 10 years give or take
15. first breakthrough book yeah the
four hour work week four hour work week
was 2007 so let's call it right 15 years
ago 15 years ago so what you said to
people
to a lot of tutting and disbelief
is that you as an individual have access
to tools so that you can find some thing
or somebody or some system that can do
the grunt work so that you can actually
do human work that is valued by others
and that opened the door for what so
many people are now capable of doing
however
there's still all this pressure to race
to the bottom if you put your freelance
work on upwork the race is to be the
fastest cheapest person
well if you're the fastest cheapest
person you're just a Mechanical Turk
you're just cranking it out and no one
cares about you because the minute
someone's faster and cheaper than you
they'll switch
and what we're looking for is
to find work where our work is
unmistakably us where our work is
something we can point to and say given
who I am and what I see I made this I
made this for you
can you please help me make it better
and when we can do that
our days are totally different than when
we're basically sure that an AI is going
to take over our job for free as soon as
the boss can figure out how to write
down what we do all day
so let's just say as a thought exercise
that
you came across through doesn't have to
be through alt MBA you end up taking on
as a mentee the 25 year old current day
version of you similar background
similar education how would you help
that Seth to do this
so I haven't run the alt NBA for a long
time I'm very proud that there's a b
Corp and it runs and lives happily
without me
and I don't have any official
mentorships and you've heard me talk
about this before because it just
doesn't scale and it becomes this pit of
yeah this is just a total thought
exercise but I need to say it because
sometimes people hear your thought
exercises and then they send me notes
[Laughter]
self-staking mentees
thank you
the subreddit Seth's mentees
the point of my work is for me to be
able to be a mentee without showing up
in person and I'm thrilled when that
happens
when someone sends me a note saying I'm
25 years old how do I become a marketer
where do I get a job where do I train
my answer is
you do it by becoming a marketer go find
a charity that you care about and go
raise ten thousand dollars for them go
to a garage sale buy forty dollars worth
of stuff and sell it on eBay for a
hundred dollars go figure out how to
tell a story to somebody else that
changes them
and if you're a receptionist at an
ophthalmologist you can do the same
thing you can figure out how to take
that person the patient who just came in
or is on their way out and make them
feel ten percent better by saying
something doing something interacting
with them not because it's in the manual
not because you memorized it but because
you see a way to connect to another
person if you can do that just a little
you can do it again
and that is the Breakthrough that
Industrials do not want us to understand
that they invented public school so we
would say will this be on the test
how little can I do and still get picked
and all three of those things are wrong
and the option instead is to say is
there a human somewhere connected to you
in person or online can you connect with
them in a way that makes things better
for them at least a little
and then can you do it again
that's what culture is that's what we've
been doing for ten thousand years
that is what fills people with meaning
and you don't need tips or tricks or
hacks like someone sending me an email
saying Seth what's your favorite color
because then if I write back somehow
we've built this sense of mutual
connection no that is not marketing
that's hustling
and hustling doesn't work anymore
because everyone's doing it and just
wait till the AI spam shows up yeah I
spam is going to make your head explode
because it's gonna be so effective until
you end up not even trusting that
[Music]
right so putting AI spam aside I agree
with you I mean honestly I'm just I'm
just enjoying my current level of spam
while I can but if people are listening
and they want to as you've outlined
create meaning do human work
not succumb to a race to the bottom
where they end up
replaceable by the next fastest cheapest
fill in the blank
do you have any other guidelines besides
get started do the thing that you are
aiming to do
or any other reasons to be optimistic I
think that might be helpful also just to
not level the scales a little bit but I
feel like optimism is often a precursor
to action
or prerequisite in a sense how would you
speak to that
and I want a footnote I did take a
a note on paper you said I think we're
going to come back to the bees if I
heard you correctly we are let's talk
about the boss
it is entirely possible that you work in
a place where you have no options you
have no agency you have no significance
if that is actually true
you should quit
because you don't get tomorrow over
again my guess is it is not actually
true
my guess is you have more agency than
you are prepared to embrace
and so
go start a book club at work start with
one of Tim's books read it with four
other people and so get on the customer
service line after your shift is over
and answer three questions and so figure
out how to engage with someone in the
organization in a way that is not part
of quote your job and figure out how to
lead and connect you can do those things
without getting fired or after work
a friend of mine got married at a old
folks home
and the person the witness was 97 years
old
and two days later she passed away
so do you think that that's going to be
a magical marriage to have honored that
person the one thing that she was
staying alive for that she got to see
before the end or do you think it makes
more sense to be a bridezilla and to
just make sure you're part of the
wedding industrial complex and
everything matches everybody else's
wedding right so in all these elements
of our life we are pushed to do
something the normal way the profitable
way the way where we are blameless or we
can choose to do something that matters
so now the bees if you don't mind I
don't mind I am fascinated by the bees
so the story it's more personal than
most stories they tell but I have been
hoping to share it with you so I'm glad
we're getting this chance to talk
I got a note I don't apply for work
anymore because airplanes feel like
cannibalism to me after working on the
climate thing I feel like I can do my
work without doing that and after a
thousand in-person speeches I've earned
the right to say no I'm not going to get
on a plane anymore
but I needed to get somewhere for family
reasons and
someone reached out and said
for family reasons I have built a firm
that's remote I'm really remote in
Australia because my daughter who's 10
was born with some health problems and
I've tried to organize our lives to
support her in having the most magical
life that she can and I'm running a
conference for the entrepreneurs
my Venture firm funds they're all in
regenerative work they're all dealing
with the climate problem from a
commercial point of view
will you come help run a two-day seminar
for them and I happen to be somewhere
near there so I said yeah I can do that
and so for free I
showed up to do this today Workshop
well the day before he reached out and
said I'm not going to be there a person
because my daughter's not feeling very
well but I'm sure it'll go great so the
person I ended up running it with is
beekeeper from Australia and he started
talking to me about the bees and he told
me the story of Jacqueline Freeman's
song of increase and the song of
increase is just such a great Tim
Ferriss story so here's what happens a
typical Hive not the big honey Hive we
could have a conversation about big
honey but a typical feral beehive at the
end of a Long Winter will have barely
made it through that's what the Honey's
for to supplies them with food during
the course of the winter but if they
made it the Council of Maidens will meet
they're the ones who really run the hive
and they will do a couple things the
first thing they will do is build a
vertical egg chamber and instruct the
queen to lay and fertilize a queen egg
which is very unusual because there's
only one Queen in a hut
and the second thing they will do is
tell the rest of the maidens to go get
as much pollen as they possibly can and
replenish the honey Supply this happens
in May and June
in the Northern Hemisphere and so what
will end up happening is The Hive will
this is 20 000 bees will be back in
ship-shaped condition by June
and then based on the weather
because they know what the weather is
going to be they're very good at this
they will
organize without an organizer lead
without a leader
000 bees will leave The Hive in a 10
minute period of time
they will leap out of the hive singing
the song of increase and Jacqueline has
written beautifully about this and then
they end up in a tree a hundred yards
away in a tight ball because bees have
to maintain a body temperature of 98
degrees or else they fall apart they get
into a torpor and now they only have
three days to find a new place to live
and each one of the bees
is doing what the bee does almost every
B except for the queen is only three
weeks old
which I didn't know I thought peace
lived a really long time and so the
Scout bees are doing their scouting and
the maidens are doing their HB is doing
their thing but the hive is basically a
human brain inside out there are neurons
all working in sync to create this Leap
Forward
and hearing the story I was completely
transfixed by what the song of increase
could mean to people
and then I realized people aren't bees
and we're looking for something with
even more internal meaning than simply
this Leap Forward
so I ended up
driving then
really far hundreds of miles to visit a
friend and early the next morning I went
for swim
with all this forgive upon buzzing going
on in my head
and as someone who swims almost every
day there was a very fearsome Riptide
and I came as close to Drowning as it is
possible for a person to come
and
as it happened I was
pretty okay with the fact that that was
the end of that
I would miss my family I would miss so
many things but it was like well that's
the end of that that's the end of that
and then this mission of talking about
significance just flooded over me and I
somehow figured out how to get back to
shore
and then the next day I heard from Dan
and his daughter Frankie had best away
and the combination of all those things
help me
realize that the world probably doesn't
need another marketing book for me but
probably could benefit from thinking
about all of those things at once and
realizing that we have so much more
power than we want to acknowledge
thank you for sharing that Seth that is
more personal
than most stories you've shared and
I'll just take a beat on that and
would love to hear
what happened after that swim after that
phone call what did the next week or two
look like for you or feel like for you
with respect to
this germinating seed maybe it was
beyond the seed of significance and
shifting perhaps to a focus on that with
your communication with your thinking
what did the subsequent week
look like
it's funny because no one's ever asked
me that but it fits right into the
question you asked a little while ago
about what can people do
I wrote a whole book in two weeks
I said how can I honor Frankie how can I
honor Jacqueline how can I honor all of
the people who are being brutalized by
billionaires in Silicon Valley how can I
honor the climate refugees how can I
honor everybody who has something to
lose
by doing the thing that some people
think I'm good at and
what could I do for Frankie that would
be better than this
and so that's why I did it because
writing a book as you know is more of a
lift than is rational and I could have
just written a few blog posts but
having people see you do this irrational
lift
helps them understand that you have
something important to say and that
maybe they'll share it with somebody
else
I'm gonna throw out
few terms actually I'll give you two two
choices
and we can go down whichever path you
choose or option C which I don't present
you're all you're good at choosing
option C when people say you can choose
between A and B so that may be where we
go wooden tiles
or Quakers where would you like to go
I learned something fascinating about
the Quakers the Quakers invented
solitary confinement
and when we think of Quakers non-violent
Etc the whole idea think about the word
Penitentiary right it's where you go to
be penitent to repent
and the idea of solitary confinement was
to create the conditions for people to
get comfortable with
their sins and to repent from them and
then across in England
they built the panopticon which was a
prison where you were under constant
surveillance so this is super low Tech
you just put the guard house in the
middle and make sure the windows are all
lined up so everyone feels like they are
being seen all the time
when we add solitary confinement
to the panopticon we end up with
surveillance capitalism we end up with
this idea not the surveillance
capitalism of consumers being
surveilled which is what the book is
about but more about workers being
surveilled that we isolate them from
each other except when they're in a zoom
call where the meeting was designed to
make sure they weren't picking up their
dry cleaning when they were at home and
counting their keystrokes and measuring
their output and Counting the clicks
constant surveillance and for many
people the equivalent of solitary
confinement well why are we surprised
that turnover is high and work
satisfaction is low because we strict
meaning from people when they go to work
because we don't trust them to be people
we need them to be resources and that's
why the very phrase human resources is
such a challenge because after you've
optimized the machines
the next thing to do of course is to
optimize the people and there's the
whole measured self movement about how
can you get better on your bike with
Strava but that's happening too at work
whether you want it to or not
um
so let's just say you're the
founder of a small company and maybe it
started off as a solo operation or
husband and wife team and good news you
seem to have
created something that people want or
indeed
and it's growing so you hire you hire
people and you have the best of
intentions you believe yourselves to be
moral people ethical people and
that husband and wife team are listening
to this podcast and they have four
employees maybe they're in a
fast-growing Bakery who knows and it
could be any type of business
they have the tiger by the tail they're
growing quickly there's not a lot of
room for under performance
because a lot of people are wearing a
lot of hats
how would you talk to those people
because they may hear this and say Yes
Seth I want to value my employees as
humans not just resources and the
reality is we have pretty tight margins
we're attempting to grow quickly we have
a lot of inventory we need our employees
to really perform at the highest level
possible and if they're not performing
we do need to let them go or replace
them
okay so we're gonna do it aside in a
minute
in my old voice about Freelancers and
entrepreneurs and growing a small
company but before we do that I want to
highlight I am not here to say we need
soft to replace hard I'm not here to say
that workers benefit when the boss goes
easy on them
in fact I'm talking about the opposite
that the significance of what can be
built by Cesar Chavez or what could be
built by the carbon almond act team for
no money has nothing to do with soft or
hard it has to do with the idea that you
make a promise and you keep it
and you need to have a lot of rigor
where you are relentlessly criticizing
the work
but you are not criticizing the worker
you earn enrollment on the change you
seek to make right that the original Mac
was built by 13 people at a pirate flag
and they worked harder than anybody in
Silicon Valley has ever worked before or
since and they didn't get paid very much
and if you talk to Susan years and years
and years later I don't know if she's
been on the podcast but she's great no
she will talk about it as being a
seminal moment in her life right because
they got something done
so that's why we need to have the aside
about
Freelancers and scale
freelancing is Magic I am a freelancer I
used to be a freelancer in between I was
an entrepreneur they are different jobs
Freelancers get paid when they work
they do the thing and it has their name
or something like it on it it's very
hard to scale freelance work what you
need to do is strip away the busy work
Outsource it and what you need to do is
get better clients because better
clients demand better work and pay you
more
but what usually happens when a
freelancer starts to succeed is that
higher Junior versions of themselves
and try to push those people to read
their mind work ever harder and faster
for less money than they get paid and
then pass it off as their work that's
super stressful and it almost never
works and so if you really
are building something bigger than the
two of you I would say tell me this
thing you're building and why some
customers will pay more for it because
you added human value because if you're
trying to out Amazon Amazon you got
troubles even Walmart can't add Amazon
Amazon that's not a race you can or want
to win
so what we see is you know if someone is
going to build
a bakery or a wedding services business
or a physical therapy
facility
they can win by racing to the Top by
saying there are people here who do work
you cannot find anywhere else
but do not expect that you're also going
to get that work faster and cheaper then
you can get it other places because you
can't have everything
and if you can make a promise to your
customers and your employees can see
there
contribution to that promise
you're not going to have any trouble at
all getting your employees to do what
they need to because you created the
conditions for better you didn't try to
manage your way into getting them to
give you a bargain
hmm
so let me take a
step off the highway onto the the
footpath the bike path on the side for a
second because this is related and very
self-interested but I'll I'll ask it
anyway since I guess this whole podcast
is pretty self-interested I get to have
conversations with people I like and
respect
but you've known me for a long time now
I would say I think I think that's a
fair way to put it we've known each
other for a decent stretch
and I I consider you very good at being
aware of your own assumptions the
constraints that you've applied to your
life
choosing the rules choosing for instance
a story about money past a certain point
right past past the requirements past
your basic needs and wants money is a
story so choose a story you can be happy
with Etc
is there anything you've observed over
time with me where you're like it's
funny you know Tim has this
has this sort of conceptual limitations
stuck between his teeth all the time and
he can't seem to see it when he looks in
the mirror he's always got that spinach
between those two teeth and it bothers
him he's always picking at it but he
can't quite get it Loose this is a very
long-winded way of asking what are some
of the maybe questions or issues that
you seem come up repeatedly with me is
there anything that comes to mind
I was completely wrong about my first
impression of Tim Ferriss
and that's because I based it on people
who didn't understand what you were
trying to do trying to do that to me
and so I was getting hustled by people
who said that you were the person who
was teaching them how to hustle and I
didn't bother to spend the time to
understand what you were actually doing
and that's completely on me
and you have developed a voice and a
contribution to the culture and your
community
faster and at a younger age than almost
anybody I've worked with and way faster
than I did
and
I don't see any spinach in your teeth I
think that it's unlikely that you knew
16 years ago that you would be having
conversations like this that you would
have built this
platform and leverage you have to teach
so many people things
but at the same time when the
opportunities have Arisen you have been
really smart about saying no I don't
want to be a judge on Shark Tank and no
I don't want to figure out how to hustle
people to pay me on Cameo you're saying
I have something
to narrate here for people whether or
not I know exactly what tomorrow is
going to be like
and it's not easy to do that regularly
at the level that you do it with the
amount that you put out so I know you
weren't fishing for me to say this but
I've needed to say it in public because
in private in my head for the first nine
months that I sort of knew you I didn't
really know you
um
I appreciate that Seth and
I should provide a little context for
folks and the context is when we have
dinner together
on the East coaster I guess it's always
on the East Coast because you're very
good at setting your Geographic pounds
I ask you for a lot of advice and you're
very forgiving and tolerant of me asking
many many questions which I really
deeply appreciate so that question came
from a a genuine place and thanks for
the very kind words I I love doing this
I love having these conversations and
there's absolutely no way I ever could
have foreseen this being my
quote-unquote job 16 years ago no way
absolutely not and I think probably four
or five years from now whatever I am
doing then
I will have the same statement for
there's no way I could have predicted
now that I would be doing that five
years from now
and let's just
to broaden that out
parents who have a stick around the back
of their car
have been indoctrinated to indoctrinate
their kids to do the same thing to say
oh you studied mechanical engineering so
you're going to be a mechanical engineer
for the next 70 years and then you'll
die and that's not what humans are
capable of that what a joy to be able to
say I have no idea what I will be saying
and doing in five years what a privilege
then it is I feel really fortunate can
we talk about false proxies for a minute
let's talk about false proxies I'll let
you lead the way okay so people might be
wondering about the wooden tile so I
have a 70 Watt laser cutter in my
basement doesn't everybody and so I make
these things that are like I Ching card
and so instead of having notes or
something I just really like the texture
of them so that's what the wooden tiles
are and so there's a wooden tile right
here that says false proxies
false proxies
we need proxies when we go shopping at
the supermarket because if you're going
to buy ketchup you're not allowed to
taste the ketchup before you buy the
ketchup so the label on the bottle is a
proxy for what's inside of it and we're
even capable as consumers to figure out
we haven't had this particular flavor of
salad dressing before but we can guess
from the other clues that it's gonna be
good or not good and we use proxies to
pick which restaurant to go to in
proxies to figure out you know what book
to buy because you're not going to read
the book until after you buy it judging
a book by its cover is a very common and
important thing
at work
we developed proxies because we have to
hire people for a 20 30 40 year career
before they work for us so one proxies
did you go to a famous college one proxy
is are there any typos on your resume
one proxy is are you good at
interviewing
but of course unless you're hiring
someone to be an interviewer
being good at interviewing is a false
proxy and yeah the thing about false
proxies is they lead to caste systems to
social stratification to Prejudice to
misogyny because we are quickly making
decisions on who to swipe left or right
based on clues that aren't actually
related to whether the person can do the
job or not if someone is in a wheelchair
they might be a great programmer whether
or not they're in a wheelchair is
irrelevant to whether they're a great
programmer and yet
it's 2023 and it's still happening so
there's all of this information that's
now available to us where we can look at
the work instead of looking at the
proxies so The Simple Solution which
I've been lucky enough to adopt is I
won't work with someone unless I've
worked with them before
and that means I will pay someone to do
a short project and I pay them whether
they do a good job or not but if they're
good at the project now I know that
they're good at the project because they
did the project
and
with all of the stuff that's happening
in our world with the rate of change
that's going on with the need for people
not who know something they learned at
school because they can look it up
online and stock overflow in two minutes
what we need are people who are
resilient and risk-taking and honest and
transparent and connected and loyal and
all these other words which don't match
up with the proxies we usually use
when we decide who to hire who to let
into an institution who to reward who to
follow online
so I think it's important to just name
it there are false proxies in our life
and they're expensive they get in the
way of our output and they also steal
our souls and they denature our culture
because when a proxy becomes important
when for example a celebrity gets the
benefit of the doubt what we've done is
we've handed this person leverage that
isn't really helping anybody
hmm did I hear you correctly Seth and if
so I'd love to hear you expand on this a
bit that you only work with people
you've worked with before did I hear
that correctly or was that a different
line yeah I know so what I mean is if
I'm going to do a project
the old way to do it was to look at the
10 million
viable people pick the one who has the
shiniest set of easily measured proxies
and hire them
and I have hired hundreds of people that
way and for a while I told myself I was
really good at it and then I thought
about it I realized I just thought I was
really good at it because of all the
people I didn't hire because they didn't
match my perception of what I was
looking for right
and what I learned particularly working
on the carbon Almanac is everyone was a
volunteer everyone got
the keys you know take the car for a
drive and if you did something that was
really good we asked you to do more
and if you didn't we asked you to do
something different because the work was
the point and so now I'm working on this
interesting
software pilot thing and I went to
people who I've seen do projects
and who I've danced with before not
based on where they live right one lived
in Nigeria one lives in London one lives
in Portland it's I've seen your work I
don't know you personally the personal
stuff is an interesting proxy but it
doesn't usually match so let's dance
again
and once we can seek enrollment once we
can say to the world
I'm looking for a freelancer who wants
to make this change in the world this
project is this size and I'm going to
pay you this much to do it
we can use our human judgment to decide
who to offer the project to but then
when the project comes back this one
hour one week project yeah pay them
fairly and then decide based on the work
product
whether it's useful this is exactly the
way Matt builds WordPress right that
automatic is a reading and writing
culture where if you're good at reading
and writing you get to do more stuff but
there's no points for being good in a
zoom meeting no one gets promoted to
them no definitely with Matt no one gets
promoted for Zoom meetings and you do
have to do some customer service which I
think is actually a fantastic practice
even even if you're c-suite you get to
spend a couple weeks answering customer
tickets question for you about employee
retention and I'd love to hear you speak
to your personal experience you've hired
many people and this may not map
directly to the writing or the
principles in the song significance it
may but I'm wondering
because hiring is one thing retaining is
a is a close cousin but not exactly the
same
and there are people out there I know
quite a few people really good at
putting in the time
to hire really good people
but they haven't been able
to for whatever reason as
thoroughly as effectively think about
retention so they lose some people who
are very very good
what have you found to be in your
experience or observing others
some of the
key ingredients or possible approaches
to ensuring that you retain High
performers
so if we look back just 50 years
the purpose of a company town
is if you are the landlord it's much
harder for someone to quit
that the goal of the old school
industrialist is that your employees
have no options because if they have no
options you don't have to pay them very
much
let's compare that to an ad agency I
read a book about them many years ago
called St Luke's in London they want
there were 30 people they want a whole
bunch of awards when you win a bunch of
Awards as an ad agency what happens is
you get a whole bunch of fancy new
clients which means you have to hire
more people which means the average goes
down and then you get big enough that
you've exhausted and you saw it to
Sachin Sachi and then you're done
and
the 30 of them looked at each other and
they said we don't want to do that
so they made a rule and the rule is
we're never going to be more than 30
people
they then said to their clients that
means
we can't take any new clients unless we
lose an old client
so they have a waiting list of clients
we have a waiting list of clients you
can go to your old clients with your
best ideas and if they give you a hard
time you can say you're fired because I
got another client ready to take your
place
and it also means that if you're only
gonna have 30 employees if someone wants
to leave let them leave there's a
waiting list that people want to work
there
turnover is a good thing when we are
doing human work not a bad thing and
what I would do if I was running a real
company is I would say
the first thing you got to do on your
first day is update your LinkedIn page
and keep it up to date
and we're going to have a resume job
finding seminar every two weeks here I
don't want you to stay here because you
can't get a better job I want you to
stay here because the conditions we've
created the work we are doing is worth
you staying here for
and then I would listen if I'm not
creating the conditions where the people
who I need to be dancing with want to
stay I have to change the conditions not
curse the people who are leaving
and this permeability is where the
future lies we don't have 40-year
careers anymore we have four month
careers or three year careers so
onboarding is faster because you can say
to somebody read everything in slack be
come to work tomorrow ready to start
because it's all there right so now
instead of onboarding you in a month and
a half I onboarded you in three hours
and because we're project oriented
turnover is a little different and if I
can keep somebody here for a long time
it's because they want to stay here
this enrollment
is the key
NAD khafla has written a book called
let's get real or let's not play about
B2B selling but the lesson of let's get
real or let's not play is simple what
promises you're going to make this week
promises about your career promises
about your learning promises to our
customers
show us your work we will relentlessly
make it better this is how we're going
to treat each other if this is the right
place for you I hope you'll stay if it's
not the right place for you I hope we
can agree that it's not but
seeking retention doesn't feel right to
me
let me just elaborate on this book
because it's overlooked and so beautiful
if you're in business to business
selling selling expensive
committed items to large organizations
large organizations can now find out
everything they need without calling a
salesperson
so the intelligent trained expensive
salesperson benefits by saying to the
prospect on the first day look
you've told me you have this big problem
you need to solve you have a five
million dollar assembly line that's
letting you down level if we can solve
this problem together
are you ready to install our system
because if it's not real let's not play
don't waste my time I won't waste yours
you're not gonna buy from me because I'm
going to take you to the golf course
you're not going to buy from me because
our RFP is going to come in cheaper than
somebody else's you want my valuable
time I'm going to engage with you and
tell you the truth and you'll tell me
the truth you're going to draw your org
chart for me you're going to tell me
other complicated products you've bought
and why your company bought them and I'm
going to get you promoted by teaching
you how to buy the thing that's going to
save your assembly line let's get real
or let's not play that kind of selling
is how you sell a 10 million dollar
product you don't do it by spamming
people and pretending you know their
favorite color
yes very true this is truth I long ago
in a former life when I had a lot more
hair and was just out of college it was
selling to CEOs and ctOS and you do not
sell expensive systems by guessing their
favorite color or even having that
conversation in fact it'll be really
counterproductive
the topic of sales makes me think of Zig
Ziglar and I'm wondering
out of my own personal curiosity were
there things that come to mind where you
disagreed with Sig maybe you respected
his position or a principle he had but
you personally did not
embrace
whatever it was that that he used as
part of his own script for navigating
the world and people is there anything
that you disagreed on
oh many things and we did it as friends
so
it's funny Zig has come up twice today
before you brought him up which is weird
I sent a picture of him holding one of
my books to someone just four hours ago
Zeke was
my teacher from afar for a long time I
memorized more than 72 hours of his
tapes I listened to the selling tapes
until they wore out and then I bought
another set and I saw him in person a
bunch of times and each time wrote him a
letter afterwards and each time he wrote
back and my letter would highlight the
things that worked and talk about the
things they didn't and
one of the highlights of my speaking
career was when he and I shared a stage
in front of 22 000 people
it was pretty cool and then I got to
publish his goals book toward the end of
his life
Zig and I disagreed about
astrology
and yoga because he was coming at it
from a different cultural point of view
from Yazoo City Mississippi and we were
like okay we can disagree about stuff
like that and organize religion and
things like that
what was interesting is when
my understanding of permission marketing
evolved and ziggs key sentence of
you can get everything in life you want
if you'll just help enough other people
get what they want kept coming up
because he meant it two ways and one of
the ways didn't work for me
he would say you can get everything in
the life you want if you help enough
other people get what they want as a way
of encouraging self-interested
short-term people to see that the best
way to get ahead was to do a favor for
someone else
because that forced empathy opened the
door to making a sale
and what shifted for me over time was
how about
you can get everything in life you want
and
you can help other people get what they
want but they're not one gets you the
other one that what we have is the
chance
to hold open the door and let somebody
else go in not because we want them to
give us something in return
but simply because holding open the door
is in itself a significant useful act
that will fuel our next cycle of War
um
we talked about it a little bit toward
the end of his life but what zigg did
for a lot of folks is help them become
professional instead of just hustling
and
I also learned a lot about living the
life of the professional speaker and I
could go on and on but if
if your listeners haven't listened to a
bunch of Zig yes it's dated but you can
find the good stuff and be glad you
choose
where would you suggest people start or
what would you suggest they search for
because the universe of Zig as you
mentioned is 62 hours is the starting
point
where might you suggest they start what
should they look for the stories in the
book sequence of closing the sale
are gold I could tell word for word the
story of the overalls
and his Original Classic CU at the top
also filled with stories
when I was starting out I failed for
seven years in a row it was a very long
slog had his tapes which you can still
get today on CD
also filled with nothing but stories
were
super dated even then but so cheesy and
wonderful that if you listen for an hour
a day you can't help but not quit and to
give us a image in time what were you
failing at over that period of time as
you listened to these audio cassettes
and wore them out
my first job was in 1983
at a software company in Boston I worked
with RCC Clark Michael Crichton Ray
Bradbury I was a brand manager I was 24
years old it was spectacular and then I
left there moved to New York and started
my own gig and just kept failing at the
book business chip Conley and I did our
first book together and then I got 800
rejection letters in a row that meant
every day I opened the mailbox and three
people had taken the time to write me a
letter with my name on it and put a
stamp on it saying we don't like your
project and we don't like you either
and it's very easy in the face that and
then you know I was just pitching and
pitching and pitching and often in a way
that amused me but was selfish and I was
pitching to people whose job was to be
pitched I wasn't calling people up on
the phone at home right this was the
head of Acquisitions at Simon and
Schuster or whatever it was but
when the rejections feel personal
if you don't have a way to keep caring
but understand that what they are
rejecting is the work not the person
it's super easy to give up
and that was the transition that I
needed to make you didn't like this idea
it's not that you didn't like me what
can I learn from your criticism of the
idea so the next one will be better
you strike me as someone who's quite
happy to have solo time
engage in Solo projects maybe a project
with a family member or something else
like building canoes that could be a
whole conversation in and of itself
how are you building are you building a
community Orchestra for yourself at the
moment or looking forward in the short
term to doing that or I should say in
the soon to be present future
and if so how are you approaching it
because this is something
that I've also noticed and this is not a
brilliant Insight but it seems to
alleviate a lot of the
existential dread and mitigate some of
the nihilism that people feel if they
simply have some type of shared purpose
or activity with a few people
consistently
how are you thinking about that for
yourself
this is just me I don't know how to
broaden this to everybody so the
reputation I had from the beginning was
I don't miss deadlines I never go over
budget and I'm going to deliver you what
I said I was going to deliver you
and no one who has worked for me has
ever been part of a layoff
people have lost their jobs because it
wasn't a good fit and I've never said
all you guys
you know we're downsized when Google
shut down squidu in one day with no
warning and no honest explanations to
why my eight co-workers and I all went
down together but the promises I make I
make very seriously
so that's good and it's bad
it means that I hesitate to make big
promises
that might create the possibility that
the big thing is going to happen
but on the other hand I can live with
the confidence of knowing that you can
count on me to keep that promise so when
I think about what am I going to do for
my next five or ten year gig
I think very hard about who am I
promising and what am I promising now so
I can't say to people what I used to say
which is we're renting this theater come
and for seven hours I will be on stage
answering questions and by the way I'm
organizing the whole thing with one
volunteer I I'm gonna serve you lunch
like that's what I used to do and 400
people would come it was thrilling to
stand there for seven hours and weave
together all the answers if I announced
I was going to do that I could sell it
but I couldn't keep that promise for
sure I don't want to do that because I
don't wanna
has my career evolves and has a
different pace
try to regain my ability to ski at high
speed not what I'm trying to do so where
is that sense of community the carbon
Almanac was that and continues to be but
there's going to be another one and I
think about whether I need it to be in
person or whether this future you and I
have been describing for so long is real
and it won't be in person because I'm
very comfortable engaging with people
who aren't sharing the same hair as me
and most of all
is it worth doing for others not am I
just here to entertain myself
the Seth what else
would you like to talk about here we can
go in a million directions
what else do you have on your on your
wooden tiles okay so I want to tell the
story of the piano cover at the B
conference and then I want to talk about
meetings is that okay
sounds great so I'm about to go on stage
in front of these entrepreneurs all of
whom have raised far more money than
I've ever raised all of whom are young
whipper Stoppers who are going to save
the planet and I need I got no slides or
anything I'm just there at this
beautiful Winery North it's like yangfil
or Booneville or something this is in
Australia or somewhere else no I haven't
been Australia in a long time this is
North of San Francisco got it and I need
a stick I need some anecdote to get
started
and off to the side is a piano in one of
those quilted piano covers can you
visualize that I can you know they have
the special custom-made piano covers and
on top of the piano
is one of those little metal things that
says do not Place anything on top of
this
and on top of that is the sign
but I can't read the sign so I walk over
because that's going to be my stick
which is did you ever notice that people
put a do not fit in and then put a sign
on top of that
and on the sign it says
this is the original Steinway Grand D
Piano
not an original the original from 1884.
and I had my story I went over and I
said
the folks who built that Steinway in
1884 had no idea that 140 years later
he would be working he would be creating
magic and we would be talking about it
and I said there's no guarantee that
what we do is going to be around in 140
years
but we could act like it might be
we could say
this thing we're doing together is not
to say you know how do we raise as much
money as we can or how do we get written
up well on this blog site or whatever
it's important
and there are lots of kinds of important
it could be important to one person it
could be important a century from now
but this idea
that the piano is still here
that just it gave me chills
um
I love that
piano cover that is wild too the
original
an experience just to be able to touch
something like that or be close to it
yeah Wild
so
meetings
I have been obsessed with these for a
long time and have lived
a different path for meetings
our friend Toby has Shopify
wrote a script that deleted
every group meeting that was regularly
scheduled in the whole company
and then the next they sent an email to
everyone in the company and said I just
bought you back
your day because if you have 10 000
employees and there are all these weekly
or daily meetings we're talking about
tens of millions of dollars of wasted
time but on top of that we're talking
about
the innervating brain deadening idea of
watching someone talk because they
couldn't care enough to take the time to
send a memo instead
or couldn't care enough to just record a
10 minute video and send it to everyone
to watch as many times as they wanted
slower faster read the transcript and
then get back to them
and Toby said if you really need the
meeting go ahead and put it back on your
calendar you're welcome
and what meetings have become so Zoom is
a miracle because Zoom eliminates
geography when it comes to be able to
connect with people
and memos were a miracle because they
eliminated time they're asynchronous
and when we add video to this what we
get is either
we're gonna have everyone get together
for an hour so I can talk at you
and I can take attendance based on you
sitting there and what we know from
surveys is people hate this it's one of
the things they hate the most about
their day
and it's a form of Power Authority
status and control
so
conversations need to happen more
meetings need to happen never
you can have conversations all day you
can have a two-minute conversation a six
minute conversation talk to this person
or that person but a conversation means
there are questions in their answers
people are talking to each other
everyone is changed at the end
a meeting is a delivery of information
for the convenience of the person who
called it
and I think it is possible I know it is
possible
we never once had a meeting the whole
time we built the carbonomina there were
times I sent a video to people and said
this is what's up watch it if you want
to but because we were in time zones
around the world a meeting wouldn't have
made any sense we had things where I
said I'm having office hours you can
come ask questions
but I didn't do that other thing and it
feels to me like the future of the
resilient organization is a lot closer
to what not does it automatic which is
how do we build this asynchronous
geography free institution it doesn't
depend on me making stuff up while I'm
on camera yeah absolutely and for people
who may not have caught his name before
Matt mullenweg is his name he's been on
this podcast a number of times
and he also has been part of a podcast
and this is I believe automatic produced
called distributed I may be getting the
name wrong but it is entirely about
distributed organizations and unorthodox
ways of approaching the type of thing
that we're discussing right now
meetings or lack thereof different means
of communication Etc and he's been
distributed first for a very very very
long time so they were incredibly
prepared albeit coincidentally for
everything that happened during lockdown
and so on well but coincidentally
everyone else was unprepared have you
seen what his team has built with chat
GPT for blogs has he shown you the
version yet I don't know if it's public
I have seen screenshots but yeah is it
public it's not public but we're only
talking so we're allowed to talk
okay go for it so if you want to talk
I'm just gonna say it is the single best
use I have seen
of chat GPT or whatever they're using
being implemented in a way where it's
not just you know a talking llama it's
actually oh yeah I need this yeah for
sure they created some amazing products
so yes that'll be the the teaser the
teaser for people yeah for things to
come I'm just here for the hype
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's what I think when I think South
Dakota
is there anything else you would like to
to chat about okay so your listeners
love tips I got one last tactic tip yeah
that changed the lives of a lot of
people and then we'll do the magical
wrap-up stuff
we invented something called page 19
thinking and we knew there was going to
be page 19 of the almanac it was going
to be written copy edited
Illustrated typeset footnoted but there
wasn't one person on our team who knew
how to make page 19.
and so we said to the team we know in
the future there will be a page 19. we
know that it will come from this group
but we also know there's not anyone here
who's qualified so what should we do
and the answer is someone should write a
paragraph of page 19 and say please make
this better and then someone else will
add to that and someone else will
footnote that and someone else will
illustrate that and we will relentlessly
criticize page 19 without one saying the
person who worked on it was wrong or
incompetent
and page 19 thinking I've always had
page 19 thinking I didn't need it but so
many people when they heard this felt
the freedom
to now speak up and contribute because
they knew it was going to get better and
if you think about it that's Apple
that's Ford that's every company you can
name right Sergey did not program the
Google you are using today
it started with a little tiny German and
someone and someone and someone and
someone and someone
when you feel stuck to slip for page 19
thinking
and is the way to look for page 19
to take the pressure off by
lowering your expectations in a sense so
that you can iterate your way to
Excellence
is this applicable to a solo shop or a
very small shop could you maybe
elaborate on on what you mean what it
could mean to embrace that thinking it
puts the pressure on
it doesn't take the pressure off it puts
the pressure on because you can no
longer be a primadonna he says I'm
afraid someone's going to punch me in
the nose because you have to say
my nose is not involved right yeah and I
heard Danny's great story about my nose
and it it made me smile
this is Danny Meyer folks for people who
don't know you after he broke my nose he
offered to straighten it out and as you
can see in the video it's still crooked
but once you understand that you live in
a page 19 world the pressure is on for
you to put out work
that can generously be criticized don't
ship junk not allowed but create the
conditions for the thing you're noodling
on to become real that doesn't happen by
you porting it until it's perfect
it happens by you creating a process for
it to get better so now you're on the
hook fish don't like to be on the hook
people should be on the hook
[Laughter]
I I love it and I was thinking of how
this might apply to my own and I have
since we last spoke been writing fiction
and shipping fiction I'm not saying it's
Ursula K Le Guin but I'm I'm happy with
it I am on the hook and have have tried
to create I haven't found exactly what I
think will be most helpful later but to
create an environment in which
perfect is not the enemy of good but
that I also have a means of not shipping
garbage right and actually having people
review my work
how do you like to solicit feedback on
writing this is I know a tangent but if
you reach out to people to
proofread or review drafts of something
you've put together
how do you enable them to be the best
proofreaders
three words and then some definitions
the three words are criticism feedback
and advice
I'm terrible at criticism don't like
criticisms you're terrible at receiving
it receiving it yeah criticizing people
no problem but being criticized not my
thing feedback
good feedback is precious but advice
advice I can handle because advice is
one human who's on the side of the other
human
helping them turn on lights now when it
comes to writing there is line editing
copy editing
developmental editing and proofreading
they do not mean the same thing
proofreading means
did the changes that were instructed to
be made get made
so proofreading is sort of trivial copy
editing says what do you think about the
Oxford comma copy editing says I don't
like the way you spelled this kind of
thing line editing says this sentence
would be better if you move the second
half to the first half that I'm going to
smooth your voice up
and developmental editing is Magic it's
I read your work let's just talk in
general about the change you seek to
make and why it could be made better in
a different way so I work with the
magical Nikki Papadopoulos at
penguin
mostly because her developmental editing
is the best I've ever encountered
she says the title of the book is wrong
and you need to move these three
chapters to the end
like what's that worth that's
spectacular but I will confess if she's
not listening that before I send her a
book
I send it to a paid copy editor who
works for me I don't work for him and
for a thousand dollars he copy edits the
book so he's not allowed to change any
of my voice but he fixes every one of
the little things
so when I send it to penguin they think
wow this guy's so good at all the
details no I'm not Dr Aker is but you
don't know he exists because I sent it
to him before I sent it to you so the
point is you will run into people who
think that the most important thing they
can tell you is you're missing a comma
in the third line This is not helpful
this is this this work is now cheap it's
free online you can just upload a file
and someone will fix it for you but
developmental editors they're Priceless
you need to find someone who has that as
a skill opinions don't matter that's why
the whole thing with logos don't show
anybody your logo and don't tell anybody
your new kid's name before they're born
because everyone thinks they have an
opinion about a logo but no one's got
expertise it's none of their business
pick your logo and do your logo the same
thing's true with your kid's name and
when you show your writing to an amateur
they're going to give you logo advice
the book isn't for them you need to
engage with people who the book is for
watch what they do with it see what
lights them up so in my case
after permission marketing
hearing people say back to me which
parts of the book resonated with them
taught me how to write the next book
because I didn't ask anybody how do I
make this book better I just said I
wrote this book what he and seeing what
they did I give them more of that
right by extension
the zig could have taken the fact that
you know the overall story
word for word and be like okay
interesting let's take a look at why
that worked and maybe I'll give him an
extra heaping dose of something like the
overall story in the next book exactly
and I know for a fact that that's
exactly what Zeke did
so Seth the new book is the song of
significance subtitle a new Manifesto
for teams people can find you at
sethgolden.com Seth's dot blog
is there anything else you would like to
add any requests you would like to make
of my audience any complaints you'd like
to Lodge formally criticisms maybe
or anything else you would like to to
say before we wrap up
I am overwhelmed with gratitude that I
get to do this and
I'm feeling the murmurs of generosity
and abundance replacing the small-minded
scarcity that was so common for so long
as people hustled their way through one
thing after another over the last bunch
of years and I think as we all come out
of hopefully come out of this worldwide
pandemic
people are taking a deep breath and
focusing on
contribution and generosity and all I
can tell you is I'm overwhelmed with
gratitude for you and for the people who
support my work just making things
better because if not that what so thank
you
um
thank you so much Seth and to everybody
listening will have everything
that we discussed in the show notes and
probably quite a bit more at tim.blog
podcast where you can find this and show
notes on every other episode and until
next time just to be a bit nicer than is
necessary to yourself and to other
people make things just a bit better
have that extra conversation say that
extra nice word do what you can it
doesn't have to be huge probably
shouldn't be huge because then you can
hide behind that as we've covered in
previous episodes make it small make it
matter and until next time thanks for
tuning in